[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
adiós a una leyenda tras un funeral con
protocolos similares a uno de estado y
que replicó muchas de las pasiones que
desata el fútbol en argentina diego
armando maradona fue sepultado en un
cementerio privado de buenos aires
hay descontento entre los palestinos en
honduras por la decisión del gobierno de
trasladar la embajada del país
centroamericano en israel a jerusalén
siguiendo los pasos de eeuu
hablamos con sus representantes en
tegucigalpa que es la segunda comunidad
palestina más grande de américa latina'
la posición se queda sin estrategias en
venezuela- los partidos mayoritarios
llaman a boicotear las elecciones
legislativas del 6 de diciembre y en su
lugar proponen una consulta virtual
rechazando los resultados que
previsiblemente favorecerán al partido
de nicolás maduro les contamos desde
caracas
pasión y caos así puede resumirse la
vida de diego armando maradona y también
su muerte en vida fue célebre no sólo
por su excepcional manera de jugar sino
que además se convirtió en un símbolo al
brotar de lo más humilde de la sociedad
argentina la villa fiorito hasta
conquistar la gloria como uno de los
futbolistas más grandes de la historia y
luego caer en desgracia por sus
adicciones
su funeral replicó su forma de vivir una
velación en la casa rosada- con
protocolos similares a un funeral de
estado que sólo puede compararse con el
de evita perón o néstor kirchner y que
llevó a las multitudes al caos por
querer darle el último adiós
maradona fue sepultado en un cementerio
privado de buenos aires donde también
descansan sus padres
la polémica leyenda falleció a los 60
años por una insuficiencia cardiaca
le preguntamos a natalio que soy
corresponsal de france 24 en español en
buenos aires- que sigue ahora tras la
muerte de este astro del fútbol
hay varias preguntas abiertas ya sabemos
que el campeonato del fútbol argentino
pasó a llamarse diego armando maradona
queremos también empezar a ver qué tipo
de homenajes habrá hacia la figura de
maradona con el correr del tiempo qué
lugares recibirán su nombre por ejemplo
esas son cosas que están por verse y
algo clave cuál será el lugar de
peregrinación de los fanáticos de
maradona de la gente por ejemplo de la
iglesia maradoniana esa peculiar
religión argentina porque el cementerio
donde fue enterrado es un cementerio
privado que no es de acceso público así
que también estaremos atento a ver a
dónde empieza seguramente en forma
espontánea concurrir la gente y por otro
lado qué pasará con la herencia de diego
armando maradona incluso es difícil por
lo que se sabe calcular la fortuna y
cuáles son los bienes y las propiedades
de maradona y como maradona tiene al
menos cinco hijos reconocidos dos de su
primer matrimonio sus hijas las más
visibles las más conocidas bueno qué
pasará con esa herencia bueno creo que
veremos muchos capítulos sobre él sobre
esta disputa que seguramente existirá
veremos sí o no sobre él
y que había realmente entre los bienes
de diego armando maradona maradona no
sólo fue conocido por su talento por la
llamada mano de dios' sino que también
fue una figura de la izquierda de
américa latina el futbolista era amigo
cercano de fidel castro y apoyo a los
gobiernos de hugo chávez en venezuela
daniel ortega en nicaragua
néstor kirchner en argentina y lula da
silva en brasil maría clara calle nos
cuenta cómo terminó el día es argentino
en la política
dos suburbios obreros de buenos aires-
marcaron la vida del astro argentino
diego armando maradona nació el 30 de
octubre de 1960 en un annus fue el
quinto de ocho hijos en una casa humilde
y vivió su infancia en el asentamiento
marginal de villa fiorito donde lo
despiden sus aficionados de maradona
pelusa se escapaba de los papás se iba a
jugar con gustavo éste era la alegría de
jugar el crecer en medio de la pobreza
no fue un obstáculo para convertirse en
un prodigio del fútbol y por el
contrario inclinó su postura política
con tan sólo 15 años debutó con los
argentinos juniors en el estadio que hoy
lleva su nombre y una década después
hizo historia en el mundial de 1986 en
lucha argentina fue el campeón pocos
años después de terminar la dictadura a
la que maradona crítica
pero más que trazar su carrera
futbolística el campeonato lo acercó al
que sería su gran amigo fidel castro
recibió a maradona en cuba luego de que
un medio local lo premiará como el mejor
deportista de américa latina
desde entonces forjaron una estrecha
relación maradona tenía un tatuaje en su
pierna con el rostro del líder de la
revolución cubana y otro del che guevara
eso y castró lo motivó a que se
internara en dos ocasiones en clínicas
de la habana para un tratamiento contra
su drogadicción fue un segundo padre
mi nombre
un hombre al cual yo
adoro
crecer en un barrio pobre y acercarse a
fidel afianzó la pasión de maradona por
la izquierda latinoamericana en vida
apoyo a líderes como los kirchner en
argentina a evo morales en bolivia y a
hugo chávez en venezuela siempre
viajando a los países y apoyando a sus
gobiernos
y es que con la muerte de maradona sale
a la superficie toda su vida la parte
más amable pero también la polémica como
el maltrato a las mujeres y la
drogadicción pero si hoy todo el planeta
habla de él es por el fútbol
el llamado pelusa vistió la camisa de
equipos de talla de boca juniors
barcelona nápoles y de la selección
argentina veamos algunas de sus mejores
jugadas y goles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no
y
[Aplausos]
aquí
vamos a honduras porque el presidente
juan orlando hernández anunció que
trasladará la embajada de su país en
israel desde tel aviv hasta jerusalén
antes de que termine el 2020 la decisión
que sigue a eeuu rompe el principio de
neutralidad de la ciudad santa y llega
tras presiones del presidente
estadounidense donald trump honduras
tiene la segunda comunidad palestina más
grande de américa latina después de la
de chile
nuestra corresponsal kenia torres habló
con los líderes palestinos en
tegucigalpa
tengo entendido que esta situación se
ventila selim canahuati es un activo
líder de la comunidad palestina en
honduras su familia al igual que muchas
del mismo origen son empresarios que dan
empleo a cientos de hondureños y aportan
al desarrollo del fútbol la
participación de la comunidad lo tenía
para estima en la economía nacional ha
sido tan notoria como fundamental para
un desarrollo sostenible no solamente en
áreas industriales la comunidad
palestina en honduras es la segunda más
grande de latinoamérica después de chile
y aunque sólo representan el 3% de la
población lideran la economía de este
país porque se mete nuestro país en esa
situación es decir de estar votando a
favor de algo que rechaza la gran
mayoría de los países miembros de las
naciones unidas- honduras reconoció a
palestina como estado en el 2011 y
aunque hay incomprensión y rechazo con
el traslado de la embajada a jerusalén
el gobierno cree que puede mantener
con palestinos e israelíes estamos
haciendo los arreglos de edificios y
ellos aquí para también hacer la
formalización esto en ningún momento
significa desconocer la pequeña
comunidad israelí del país está
optimista con las promesas de
inversiones
en beneficio de ambos de ambas naciones
que tienen mucho en común no sólo la
parte de cooperación de agricultura y
demás sino que hay investigaciones
honduras se convertiría en el tercer
país tras guatemala y eeuu en trasladar
su embajada a jerusalén
y a pesar del rechazo de internacional
el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro insiste en celebrar las
elecciones legislativas previstas para
el 6 de diciembre el grueso de la
oposición liderada por juan guaidó ya ha
dicho que no va a participar en lo que
califica de farsa los partidos
opositores que sí participan no están
afiliados a why dog y de hecho están en
una mesa de diálogo con maduro que waldo
quien es reconocido por más de 60 países
como el presidente de venezuela no
legítima por lo que todo indica que el
gobierno de maduro obtendrá la mayoría
en la asamblea nacional nuestra
corresponsal en caracas
herminia fernández nos cuenta más
[Aplausos]
el líder de la oposición juan guaidó no
podrá participar en los comicios
parlamentarios del próximo 6 de
diciembre a su partido y a varios otros
un fallo legales quitó las tarjetas
electorales y por eso llamó al boicot de
una consulta simbólica online para pedir
nuevas elecciones presidenciales
[Aplausos]
de diciembre en venezuela hay intentos
de fraudes de arrebatar y de usurpar el
parlamento por vía de los hechos la
exigencia del pueblo venezuela en una
acción libre justa y verificable si yo
quisiera postular me hoy en ese proceso
no pudiera porque la dictadura lo
prohíbe al igual que a más de 400
perseguidos por el régimen la minoría
opositora que sí está habilitada
participar son los que hacen parte de la
mesa del diálogo con nicolás maduro
los socialistas en un intento de darle
credibilidad a las elecciones
parlamentarias insisten que se
inscribieron más de 105 organizaciones
políticas y que apenas el 30 por ciento
son afectas al gobierno nacional
de las apuestas radicales de una derecha
difusión mejor
de sectores de oposición a las
elecciones mientras el gobierno une sus
estrategias para recuperar la asamblea
nacional la oposición está más dividida
que nunca por una parte why do intenta
mantener su liderazgo otros opositores
pretenden actuar desde el exilio y
también están quienes se niegan a un
pacto unitario con un círculo vicioso
donde distintos que tienen diferencias
tácticas y estratégicas y eso un reto
que también tiene que hacer la oposición
porque piensan mucho en egos piensa
mucho en miran y partidos de que tiene
que hacerlo y es normal en el sentido de
que todo partido va a buscar para estar
en el poder
todo indica que el próximo 6 de
diciembre el gobierno socialista
obtendrá la mayoría de la asamblea
nacional mientras tanto la oposición que
atraviesa una división profunda se
enfrenta a un panorama incierto donde no
le quedan espacios políticos para lograr
la salida constitucional de nicolás
maduro termina fernández para las 24
para paz
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí a américa recuerden que pueden
ver más emisiones en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas sigan viendo france24
[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de fran